[Music]
so
all right hello everyone
hi welcome it's so good to see your
faces
so glad you are here with us tonight so
glad that you're here with us online my
name is karen miner
welcome to the table i have a couple of
announcements
and the first one is a good one
it's my pleasure to have our children's
director
brittany johnson to come up and give our
first announcement of the night
have at it hello good evening
okay um so i'm supposed to be announcing
that we need help in the kids ministry
um we do have a kids ministry right now
we have
one class for just our school age kids
but we would really like to be able to
open up the nursery and the preschool
room
in the next couple weeks and we
are so close to having enough volunteers
to be able to do that
where you would only the
goal is to only be on every third week
and right now we have it almost to where
we can do every other week
in each of the classrooms so um
if you love working with kids we would
love to have you
these are a really great group of kids
we love them we love getting to love on
them each week
and getting to show them jesus and um
yeah they're just really cool kids and
they're really fun to hang out with i
get to hang out with them almost every
week
and i love it that's where i experience
jesus so
i really love being in there and i know
the volunteers that we currently have
love being in there
but we need more so um to be able to
open those other classes
uh oh if you wouldn't mind putting your
name
and your phone number in email and then
just in the comments section
put that you want more information about
kids ministry if you
are interested cool thank you thank you
i'll take that thanks
thank you brittany and if you do fill
out that card you can drop it in the box
that is back there on uh the small
little table
out in the foyer you could also leave it
on your chair if you like we'll make
sure to pick it up
online if you're interested in helping
in kids ministry
you can just comment or kick us a
message and
we'll make sure to get in contact with
you as well the other announcement
is next weekend is memorial day weekend
and yay and we are not having church
that sunday we really value
rest rhythms and back in between
christmas and new year's we took that
sunday off in between
and we're going to do the same for
memorial day so it's our twice a year
rest
sunday it just gives time for all of us
our volunteers our ministry leaders to
rest spend time with loved ones and
so we invite you to do that as well so
we will not be here next sunday we will
not be online next sunday
but we will be back the following sunday
which is june 1st i believe first sunday
in june so we look forward to being with
you all again then
as we transition into musical worship
let's just take a moment
to take a deep breath center on god
and remember what brought us here this
evening so will you pray with me
god thank you for tonight thank you for
bringing us together again
help us to center on you this evening to
remember that you are
in all over all that you are always with
us
god open our hearts and our eyes and our
minds for whatever it is you have for us
tonight
help us to remember that we are loved
more than we know
and that our hope is in you we breathe
a deep breath in
exhale
we are filled with your spirit so god be
with us tonight
it's in jesus name that i pray amen
[Music]
thanks karen well if you guys want to
stand
um if you have the energy to stand up
with us
i love um having the freedom to enter
into worship however
feels best to you but sometimes having
our
bodies moving is a great way to kind of
connect
holistically with what god might be
doing in our hearts
so occasionally for me
that means that my hands get involved
like if something rings true
i might raise my hands or close my eyes
if i'm wanting to focus on the words um
but i just feel like any time that we're
engaging as many senses as possible
it's just a great way to holistically
get to know what god is doing and kind
of tune our attention towards him
so i just invite you guys into that
space with us and
if that looks like sitting down then you
have the freedom to do so
um but if you want to stand if you want
to sing along please
join us in that way too all right
we're going to start with a song called
springtime
which seems appropriate since our summer
seems to continually be pushed back by
rain
i don't know if you guys are getting
tired of rain yet
i am because all my gardening projects
keep getting delayed over and over and
over
um but i know it's also a beautiful time
to actually soak in the transition when
texas sometimes can jump right into the
heat at least we have that little hiatus
right now
so uh let's kind of find the gratitude
you know in the season that we're in and
also i wanted to introduce caitlin this
is her first time up here with us
i'm so excited to have her up here yay
caitlyn
and you guys know gary and noel so y'all
worship along all right
[Music]
you're the resurrection
that we waited for
you buried the night
and came with the morning
you're the king of heaven
all the praise is yours
the longer the quiet
the louder the core is over
[Music]
the winner we will sing a new song
let
[Music]
your love hallelujahs like springtime
like springtime
[Music]
you're the living water
the deeper you call us
[Music]
that hallelujahs fall like a river
we're coming back to light
reaching towards the light your love is
like springtime
[Music]
and like a garden i will grow
oh
[Music]
we will sing a new song
is
[Music]
hallelujah
your love is like springtime
worthy of every song we could ever
sing
worthy of all the praise we could ever
bring
worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe we live for you
jesus the name above every other name
jesus the only one who could ever
save
[Music]
worthy of every breath we could ever
breathe
[Music]
there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes in wonder and show me
who you are and fill me
with your heart and lead me
in your love to those
[Music]
worthy of every song we could ever
sing
worthy of all the praise we could ever
bring
worthy of every breath we
[Music]
jesus
jesus the only one who could ever save
worthy of everybody
[Music]
there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes in
wonder and show me
who you are and fill me
with your heart and lead me
in your love to those around me
holy there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes in
water show me
who you
[Music]
lead are in your love to those around me
i will build my life
upon your love
[Music]
i will not be
shaken i will build my life
upon your love
it is a firm foundation
i will put my trust
in you alone
and i will not
be shaken holy
there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes
[Music]
show me who you are and fill
me with your heart and lead me
in your love to those around me
[Music]
thank you
we do want lives
that are centered around the person of
jesus
around his goodness his grace
and the way that he cares and loves for
everyone
yeah we believe that's who you are jesus
tonight with that in mind we want to
enter into the prayer of the people
right now
so i'm going to read through a short
prayer and
if you guys would like to join in that
with me at the end of the lines it says
we pray to you and we can all say that
together
and then there will be a space um that
will leave where you guys can
join in by sharing someone that might be
on your heart or a situation or moment
um that that you're carrying and this is
an opportunity
for us to lift that together before god
and
as a community remember those
around us who are in need of jesus who
are in need
of grace and goodness and light in their
lives
so we just invite you guys to share one
of those names speak it out and we will
also
um karen will be watching our live
stream and if anyone
online is with us tonight who would like
to share something that's on their heart
um someone's name or situation then
karen will read that out
for us as well so please um join in
whether you're with us in person or
online
and then i'll close us out with a short
prayer at the end
and we do ask that you just keep it to a
name and not give details of
someone else's private information so um
let's join into this time together
jesus for the city of saxi texas and for
every city and community
and all of those who live in them we
pray
to you for the good earth that you have
given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you for the old and the sick
for the widow and orphan for the injured
and suffering
we pray to you for the poor
and oppressed the unemployed and
destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you lord we know that you
love us
and that you hear us and so we lift
these names in situations
up to you
is greater far
than tongue or pen
can never tell
it goes beyond
the highest star
and reaches to
[Music]
the lowest
the guilty pair
bowed down with care
god gave his son
to win
his daring
[Music]
before we go into the second verse if
you wanted to share a name go ahead
from online gerald and nancy
jaden
[Music]
from online leslie
mental health
[Music]
foreign
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence
[Music]
amen
when years of time
shall pass away
in earthly thrones
and kingdoms fall
when men who hear
refuse to pray
on rocks and hills
and mountains call
god's love's so sure
still still endure
how measureless
and strong redeeming grace
to adam's race
the saints and names
oh love of god
how rich and pure
how measureless
and strong it shall forevermore
endure the saints
and
[Music]
song
could we with ink
the oceans fill
[Music]
and we're the skies
of parchment
[Music]
by train to
write the love of god above
would drain the old
show
those stretched from the sky
to the sky
how rich and pure
how measureless
and strong it shall forever mooring door
the saints in name
how measureless
then strong it
shall foreign
[Music]
yes jesus thank you that your love is so
vast
so wide so deep
that it is beyond what we can even
understand
[Music]
what we can even grasp with our human
mind would we
live into that love would it give us
grace for ourselves and for others
would it give us hope
[Music]
would it shine light on our darkest
moments
[Music]
would it set us on a rock when all we
find around us is mud
[Music]
thank you for the love of god
thank you that it reaches each one of us
no matter where we've been
no matter where we've are
we love you jesus we invite you into
this time
with us amen
thank you guys so much for joining into
that with us if y'all want to turn
and just wave to the people around you
say hello quickly uh brett will get us
started with our message in just a
moment
well good evening everyone grace and
peace
y'all doing well yeah yeah yeah cool
cool
awesome well it is uh such a privilege
just to be with all of you
and um i want to give a special welcome
to
anyone who is new uh and those who are
joining us online
you are you are not forgotten we love
you lots
and um yeah just it's such a joy to i
don't know just to have space
every sunday to come together and um
just re-center on christ
you know in this way it really is um man
it's a it's a gift it's one i mean well
we had a taste of it right the last year
of the only way we could do it was
online
and so um you know it's it really is a
privilege to
have the flexibility to either join that
way or to be here in person that's
that's really cool
so um all right i wanted to
um kind of give a little bit of an
overview because we are in
our last um this is our last
sunday for our series
um and real quick a tech thing i think i
might be coming through on the monitor
and i'm so i'm hearing myself a lot um
so we have been like y'all we've i was
kind of looking back through and seeing
like how much we've covered
and we have been a little bit of
everywhere in this series
um i mean it's it's in ways it's i mean
it's a big topic we've been the the
series title is new normal
so we've been kind of looking um into
kind of all that it means um coming out
of this year of a pandemic where you
know normal was just completely upended
for us
and saying like well okay uh everything
kind of got shaken
in my life and so now i'm having to
grapple with the fact
of like what kind of got shaken all the
way to the ground
and just got destroyed and whether that
is you know
identity things beliefs about myself
about the world
um practices i had ways and rhythms good
or not so good
um that i was living into that all of a
sudden this pandemic hit and like
it it just didn't it didn't stand up uh
and and so we've been kind of asking the
question what would a new normal look
like
um what are the life-giving vibrant
healthy
um practices we could engage um that
might be a little a little more of a
firm foundation something rooted in
um in christ so that's kind of what this
series is about so i was
looking back through um and week one uh
we
talked about the fact uh some of you
were here for this one uh that people
are not in our way
but they are the way anyone here for
that one
and uh we kind of we just named that our
really our highest
call is loving others um
in week two it was the idea that
busyness
um is not maybe what if it's not so much
our disease
but our drug in other words what if
we've been so busy for so long
we thought we were kind of a victim of
busy and yet weirdly
over time now we're kind of
almost addicted to the go go go go go
that all of a sudden when the pandemic
hit and it was like
well life is a lot slower maybe a number
of you kind of experience like oh gosh
like it was nice for two weeks and then
it's like
yeah i'm kind of getting depressed here
you know like we kind of needed the
stimulation
and the the franticness does that kind
of make sense so what we talked about
was shifting from busyness to wholeness
that was on that week two message um in
week three
it was the idea that um all of life
is interconnected all people we are much
more connected than we realize
which which means um our thoughts our
words our actions even our feelings
are much more contagious than we realize
right we people are catching who we are
um both for good or for ill
and weekly that was three week four um
was that to be christian is to find the
alleluia in everything
and and the idea there um that we could
i said we could either
um reject our life in a spirit of
complaint
or or i can receive my life in a spirit
of thanksgiving and gratitude
the choice is ours right oh i could kind
of feel that resonate with i saw
some heads nodding maybe i should have
just done that message over again i
don't know it seemed to
really connect that was week four sorry
that's not tonight we're moving on
uh next this is last week um
was was basically the idea uh that
in in us in such a season where we were
kind of um
beaten down well which basically we
talked about wounds um
and this was true especially the last
year but even before that the kind of
little picture was wounds
story identity if you were here you'll
remember that and the idea
was we have a wound of some sort i don't
mean necessarily physically it could be
like a physical illness
or it could just be emotional it could
be some trauma for our past some abuse
or neglect
words that a very important person in
our life spoke over us you know whatever
the thing it's
different probably for everyone um but
we have a wound and then what we need is
we have to be
really careful careful about the story
we tell
about that wound because it's gonna
shape our identity in such a profound
way so what we talked about was
bringing christ kind of into that moment
into that
storytelling so that it's not this thing
happened and i'm completely defined by
that and honestly there's nothing i can
do i'm just messed up now because of
that thing
right that's a kind of very
disempowering story
but instead of saying god is with me
christ is with me
the spirit of god is filling me and
empowering me to move forward so yes
that
very crappy thing happened but but
praise god
he's with me and and and now i am
empowered and and actually you might
even say like
stronger for having experienced that
awfulness
can you see how like that becomes a very
different story and then again that
forms your identity now in a more
powerful way
so that was last week and that of course
brings us to this week this is part six
and uh the final message um in this
series it's titled a little bit strange
of a title from roar
to surrender it will make sense in like
three minutes
um so our primary texts are going to be
john chapter 6 verse 38 um in james
chapter 4 verses 7 through 8. so i chose
these two passages because um
i i want to just make sure it's really
clear that
um the jesus well basically that it's
not just this isn't just for jesus
the james passage names that the same
thing jesus
it's it's us too so here's the john
chapter 6 jesus speaking
he said for i have come down from heaven
not to do my will
but to do the will of him who sent me
isn't that kind of extraordinary i mean
because if you think of anyone who could
say
like i am here and honestly
it's kind of about me and my own agenda
and what i want done
in this world because all of y'all are
extremely messed up and i am the son of
god
so everyone get in line and here we go
i've got a thought i've got an opinion
right i've got an agenda here i mean
anyone that could say that and yet jesus
himself
says i'm not here just to do my will
i'm here to do the will of him who sent
me i think that's
so profound and and if that was true for
jesus
how much more true for who
for us right uh which is the james
passage james chapter 4
verse 7 and 8. he says submit yourselves
then to god
resist the devil and he
will flee from you
so this week i had a great little moment
i was walking into the kitchen
and i had my empty glass and i was gonna
get some water so i walk over and i turn
to the fridge
and i press it in you know to the little
dispenser
and uh all of a sudden i hear behind me
this sound it was
that's what i heard um
you don't look scared uh honestly i
wasn't either i could tell this was a
tiny person
this is not this is not an adult you
know this is not an anna wild animal
this you know someone trying right it
was probably a little higher but
you know and i turn around and
uh it is my niece uh it's
shiloh she is three and
she i look back at her and she has her
hands up like this
like claws and her teeth she was like
that and she does it again she's like
she kind of put even a little more oomph
behind it just
[Music]
and you know i'm me being the good uncle
that i am i'm like okay i can see this
this moment is important to you so and
probably good for your development so
i'm going to like play along and so i
said
oh my goodness oh my oh you scared me
shiloh and
she did it again oh my god oh
gigantic she just kept doing this
over and over
and i said what what are you shiloh what
a are you
a lion she didn't answer didn't you just
rarr i said are you a tiger
i said what manner of beast are you
and she looked at me and she said
brett uncle brett hunger brett
it's me shiloh
and i was like of course
now i'm reflecting on this little moment
because it was easy for me to kind of
walk into the
my room and and kind of ignore it but i
thought you know like
what a fascinating little like what was
she doing
what was going on there exactly
and there's a um uh i often talk about
the the idea of the two halves of life
um that richard rohrer talks about this
quite a bit
and i like it because it's not about
like
um kind of looking back on our earlier
development
and kind of being either ashamed of it
or speaking down about it like oh that
was dumb or oh my gosh i used to be such
an
idiot you know like oh how embarrassing
what i like about it is that he names
like yes it's important that we continue
to grow and mature and move on
um and kind of grow up and leave some
things behind but that's not about
looking
back at the past and saying oh my gosh
so embarrassing or even looking at
others see this is key
others who are still at that stage and
being a little judgy
right because like oh i've kind of moved
on from that so i really like this
language of the two halves
of life and so i was thinking like i
wonder if that's kind of a picture
of the first half of life and by the way
when i use the first half of life he
doesn't mean
um it literally like you know zero to 40
and then 40 to 80 in this exact moment
right it's it's kind of people can kind
of be launched in the second half their
life
in their mid-20s if the suffering is
deep enough or certain circumstances
aligned or you could be
you know 85 and still kind of working
out the first half of life right
so it's kind of metaphorical but i think
it's helpful language
and so i was thinking of that roar kind
of um you know this perspective
um from that and i thought you know what
was she doing that that
roar like what was she learning
and i think you know i wonder if she's
kind of sane it's kind of like she's
trying something on isn't that what kids
do kind of when they play it's like
they're
i've heard someone uh maybe it was a
child therapist or someone said the the
work of children is play
and i thought and that kind of true like
that's kind of her work you know she
what was she doing
i think she was kind of saying like hey
i'm somebody
you know like hey don't ignore me you
know like i'm somebody
and watch this i can have an impact on
you
you big person in fact i can maybe even
make you a little bit afraid
you know roar and i shuddered right and
that was kind of my role right it's to
show
yes you can you are you are a strong
person you are power you do have some
power
look at you find that voice shiloh right
isn't that kind of the
moment this is why we know like adults
you need to kind of play along with that
and not be like hey stop it
you know i'm not even afraid of you like
that would mess it up right like no
i play along because why because shiloh
i mean yes she's three
so clearly what kind of half of life is
she in obviously
she's very much in this first half of
life and so what's she doing she's
she's learning to develop and find that
sense of self
that sense of i am a somebody and i have
a voice
and i have power hear me roar
you know like here we go it's it's kind
of like that's the season
and um and i was thinking actually about
my message
last week about the whole you know wound
story identity and i thought
huh that was kind of a roar
message like you know don't be
mousy don't say you have no power like
god is with you god is on your side the
spirit of christ is here and present
and so don't shut it down like say yes
to it and move it was almost like me
kind of for 30 minutes saying like come
on everyone let's practice
you know all right like kind of a it was
very first half of life
kind of you know message um and it also
reminded me of
self-help books i've heard this in in
christian circles it's kind of popular
at times
they kind of put down self-help books
you know
and i get it because i mean even the
name you know self-help almost the ideas
you know
it can sound a little bit kind of
you know lack of god you know kind of
atheist like i'm just gonna develop
myself
but i think often that's not really what
people mean by i think
often it's just you know what it is it's
just a first half of life thing
that's really what it's about right it's
like hey i've gotta learn to adult here
and so i'm gonna like read some books
and learn
and grow and you know develop
myself and um and so
you know even as a pastor i think we
need to invite god into that process but
i'm not like
opposed to that right in fact it's
cringy
when someone doesn't do that in the
sense of
really embrace the first half of life
and grow and mature and be
launched like into that second
half but here's the thing um
the question kind of in my mind for
tonight
is is what comes after
the roar what comes
after the self-help books maybe a few of
you are like
super into the self-help books and
you're like always reading the self-help
books and it's just been you know you're
like
going to town on the self-help and what
i'm naming tonight that's not bad
right like that's that's a first half of
life and you're growing and you're
finding your voice and your power
and your adulting and like all the
things that's awesome
but what happens after like 30 40 50
years of
developing the self empowering the self
growing into myself we even have
language for this like i've just got to
find
myself maybe you've said that at some
point in your life like
and that's important right you actually
do need to find yourself but the
question is
is that all there is
or is there something else
is there a deeper
calling i won't even say higher because
it's not so much about ranking
right like that's the important season
and this is you know what it's
is there a deeper calling is there
somewhere else that god
is calling you to go the way we might
put it um
is i think we start our walk with christ
in order to improve ourselves
but we end it with the act
of doing what surrendering
ourselves can you kind of see this
this idea because it's almost like you
need the first half
in order to have something to surrender
right this is where i think shiloh in
the season she's in that's important
we do we need to kind of grow and
develop
and you know kind of develop our roar so
to speak
that i think that's important i think
god can bless that and be with us
in that as we kind of find ourselves in
our voice and our power
but the thing is eventually i think god
calls us to this place of saying you
know what
i've been doing this for like 20 30 40
50 years now
and i'm starting to realize that it's
not all
just about me and my
capacity to
get my way roar
there's something else god
is calling me to calling us to
and i mentioned in week one of this this
series that i am
uh myers-briggs intj enagram five
that may mean nothing to you but it says
that i
am what am i i mean
i'm a kind of a driven person
but i like my control i was thinking
back on like my little um
just kind of where i've gone in my life
um
i love i'm kind of you know cerebral
kind of figured out person
a planner a scheduler which worked out
real well for me in like high school for
example i was into club swimming
and my goal at that time was to get to
the olympics that was like my goal even
though
if you look at me do i look like michael
phelps
not in the cards but boy i tried hard
and i love and i love storm practice
because it was just
you have a plan and you're just swimming
there and back and forth and just out
suffering people that's the whole game
it's like yes i may not be powerful but
i can outlast you
you know and that was kind of my thing
and then i finished that
and then i got my early 20s and then i
was into triathlons the whole swim
bike the run like yes just have a plan
stick to the stinking plan and say i
don't feel like it today
i don't care we're going and that was
like
that was just my thing of like get the
plan
have the plan follow the plan have the
structure
i'm like the structure guy the schedule
like yes and then in my late 20s right
before kids this kind of all got
eliminated with children
but right before the kids it was
marathons again it's like the same thing
right of just have the plan follow the
plan get the structure
think it through like it was like this
was the whole game
and looking back now i can see it was
incredibly first half of life kind of
stuff
but again it was important for me but
here's the thing i can just see
god like it's probably he's probably
been knocking my door
metaphorically speaking for like 10
years of like come on brett keep going
because what i can see now kind of
looking back
um now i'm in my 30s i turned 37 week
from today
um i i can basically i'm having to kind
of
accept and recognize this slightly
terrible
but inescapable fact some of you are way
ahead of me on this
so don't laugh but it just i'm dense it
takes me a while
i am not in control
off that's painful even to say out loud
some of you i should see a little bit of
a shudder go through you
some of you have been in the second half
of life for a while and you're like
yeah bro glad you're finally figuring
that out but
it's a hard it's a hard lesson why
because the first half of life is all
about
roaring it's all about naming i have the
power
and i i'm in control you know and it's
true
in a sense but there's some really of
like some really deep and profound ways
where it's totally not true and that's
what the second half of life
is about so i'm like i mean in many ways
we're right back to john
you know 6 38 this is jesus for i've
come down from heaven
not to do my will
but to do the will of him who sent me
what does jesus mean by will what's
what's our will
it's about learning to roar
isn't it it's about learning it's about
it's about learning our own power
is to declare just like a little shiloh
although we just get better and better
and better at it
i can do things
i can say things i can impact people in
the world
and again you can see how that's
important because otherwise you're just
getting
bullied and pushed around through life
right so that it's important
so here's what happens in the first half
we're developing that but then
god in his terrible horrible
wonderful beautiful grace and mercy
sends circumstances into our lives
that reveal to us what truth we
are not in control
it's a it's a brutal brutal lesson
we are not in control
and that by the way um well i say it's
brutal
it's it's beautiful and we'll get to
that actually in just a second but i
think this was one of the key lessons
in sights of the pandemic wasn't it like
all of us
folks who thought like oh yeah i got a
plan i got a plan
vacation scheduled for such and such day
here's the plan all of a sudden
just all our plan there your calendar
went just
and all of a sudden we were confronted
with the fact oh my gosh
i'm not in control
and i think honestly this is something
um well we can't have a decision make
don't we like this is something we can
be bitter about and we can
rage against god and the world about or
is something we can live into and
embrace not just
accept but this is something where we
can begin
to surrender to the one
whose will we are called to submit and
surrender to
the father who's saying look
i'm calling you to something
and i need you to get through your head
that it's not
just about you
it's just not about you
and i'm speaking i mean i'm speaking to
myself here just to be clear i'm not
putting this on like this is
a constant lesson for me this community
even leading this community
it is not about me
and my family it's just not about
me and my will and getting my way in
every moment in circumstances it's
right and same for you right and this is
what's so remarkable is
if you think of it like it's not even
just about your work or family i mean
it's literally
i think it's really living into every
breath every moment
lord you are god and i am not
not my will but yours be done
and i know this all sounds maybe it
sounds a little gloomy i'm trying to
feel you all out right now
you can i don't feel a little gloomy i
want to say that here's the beautiful
part to all this
is that if you've been around some folks
who have walked with christ for a while
i'm thinking you know not like five
years but you know 20
30 40 50 years
often if they've really embraced not
only that first half of life but they've
really matured and grown in the second
half
they are super chill have you noticed
this
like have you been around someone who's
you know got some gray hairs and like
you come to them like oh my gosh it's
just i lost my job
you know or whatever the latest crisis
just who am i i don't even know who i am
anymore you know just
and they're like oh sweetie it's gonna
be okay it's all right little buddy you
know just
it's so right and there's a stability
why because they've
learned i'm not in control
but i trust i trust
god's got me and so honestly i think
it's actually a beautiful invitation
it's a brutal it's a difficult lesson
but it's actually a really beautiful
invitation
where we can finally relax
and submit and surrender and and so as
we um
as we close i wanted to um
kind of open it up for
[Music]
well let me frame it like this my
suspicion is you know a lot of things
i'm naming here this idea of
surrendering to god submitting to god
trusting god with all things that it is
probably a not like oh
you know i've never heard that idea
before
i'm guessing you know this is maybe
something you've been kind of trying to
live into for a while and so
um kind of what i want to do is open it
up a little bit
um for some input on what has helped
you in in kind of this journey of going
from
control to this kind of letting go
and this trust this surrender i'm
thinking whether it's practices
maybe spiritual practices or i don't
know maybe it's not so quote unquote
spiritual i think everything's spiritual
but you know what i mean um
and and also don't worry about like what
oh my gosh it needs to be profound
i need to be very very profound um no no
it doesn't have to be profound
and um karen if you wouldn't mind kind
of tracking online for anyone
our online viewers if you all want to
chime in with a comment or anything i'm
just
honestly i'm kind of curious as to what
god
has kind of been teaching some of you
about like how to surrender and how to
kind of grow into this because as you
can hear i
am a little bit new to all these things
and still have a long way to go
um so at any rate i'm just going to open
it up anyone that would like to share
um what you've been learning in this
regard things that have been helpful
for you
empathy empathy
yeah realizing my perspective isn't the
truth
oh yeah gary said empathy
learning to realize that my perspective
isn't the truth like
capital t oh
that's a that's a tough one yeah
beautiful thank you
anyone else what else what else what
have you been learning about
a lot of surrendering
yeah yeah so chris was naming that idea
of acceptance
and especially you mentioned health kind
of health related thing that's that's a
moment isn't it like
when it's things around health because i
don't know maybe even like a job or
think well i'll get out there and i'll
just
find a new one you know and i can don't
worry i'm still in control i'm still you
know
but boy health that can be so profoundly
humbling
of like oh i'm all of a sudden i'm not
even in control of like my own body
and yeah thank you chris that idea of
accept accepting
god's new normal for me um
that's really really beautiful really
profound thank you
anyone else
say that one more time
again oh giving things over to god and
then not taking them back
that's easy right that's a prayer where
we pray like lord i just give this to
you it is
all yours so just put it in your hands
and then
like 10 minutes later it's not quite
going how i wanted it just okay give me
the bag you clearly can't be trusted
yeah so giving it to god but then trust
in tr really entrusting it to him not
just immediately grabbing it back
that's really good yeah awesome how
about one more
anyone
learning to forgive that yeah
there's a sense of i never even thought
of the the connection between kind of a
sense of
maybe control or even a sense of kind of
power in unforgiveness you know of like
no no no no
i'm not letting this go you can kind of
hear in that this the same kind of
grasping but then even forgiveness is
this sort of act of
oh not my will lord not my will yours be
done
wow that's that's really really profound
yeah was there is there anyone online or
i don't want to leave them
yeah just let go and let god let go and
let go yeah
yeah just a sense of of i mean that's
really the message in a way
let go let god y'all thank you
thank you thank you for that insight um
uh was there anything else before i
was that good this is from online
surrendering to me is trusting
that god will work whatever situation
for our good
yeah beautiful
well i think um you know that's the
that's the call that's the journey and
for those of you who are
solidly in that first half of life
that's okay
that's good develop that roar
go for it and keep in the back of your
mind
as i grow in god um
i'm also gonna have to keep learning to
let go
and and not just take that control um
and for those in the second half embrace
it go with it learn
to surrender all right let me pray for
you
lord jesus i
i just thank you for this community i
thank you for the deep wisdom
and um just what you're just the
profound things you're doing in people's
lives
god may we be a community that isn't
just about our roar in and
in our own identity in the things we're
called to
god may we um may we learn to let go
may we learn to empower others may we
learn to listen maybe learn to
follow and trust the winds of your
spirit
god may we surrender ourselves
our lives our families our health
our relationships and friendships and
marriages and our jobs
got all the things we're just so tempted
to hold tightly to
and kind of crush in the process lord
would you help us learn
to let go to trust you
we love you jesus it's in the powerful
life-changing name of christ that i pray
amen
[Music]
so
you brought me to the end of
myself
and this has been the longest
just when my hallelujah
was tired
you gave me a new song
and i'm letting
[Music]
i'm letting
falling into
i confess i still get scared sometimes
but perfect love comes rushing
in
[Music]
and all the lies
the is you begin
and i'm letting go
i'm letting go
cause you remind
[Music]
till i'm totally undone
with your arms around me
fear has no match for your love and now
you've won
me
you remind me
[Music]
me fear has no match for your love and
now you've won
me and i'm letting
go
i'm letting go
[Music]
and i'm letting go
letting go
falling into
[Music]
so that process of letting go and
surrendering and remembering that we're
not in control
that doesn't go well when we're by
ourselves i've tried that
it doesn't go well it doesn't it might
work for a day or two but it doesn't
last we need to do that in the context
of community
so that's why we're here that's why we
do this is to remember that we're not
alone
we have god with us and we have each
other so if you need prayer somebody to
talk to
please reach out whether it's here
whether it's sending us a message online
we want to be that community for you
also we have the cards there should be
one
near you wherever you're sitting whether
you're visiting with us and just want to
reach out to make contact or you have a
prayer request or
you'd like to join brittany in kids
church please take the time to fill that
out with your contact information
and drop it in the box right outside the
door back here or you can also pick us a
message online
um also uh i would like to have brett
come up he's gonna
share something uh very special with us
tonight
so something um it will only take a few
minutes but we're trying to kind of
start incorporating into our service is
welcoming
um new folks to the table like those who
who
um normally the process they'll go to
our welcome to the table class and then
end up
like saying yes i really like this
community i want to join so
um we're uh kind of doing some quick
little intros
just so that folks know like kind of
who's here and what's their name and you
know things like that so
um we won't be doing like you know a
dozen of these in one night i'm just
gonna do
one um for tonight and so if you will
give a hand for mariah
kent is gonna make her way up
there you go so um hey
here how about i'll give you a little
distance and then you can take off your
mask that way people can kind of see
your face
um so i'm glad i put makeup on the
bottom half of my face
didn't you didn't skimp you weren't like
trying to wear that mask anyway
okay so mariah can you share a little
bit just how you kind of found your way
like to the table
yeah um so 2020 being a super hard year
um at the beginning of the year i don't
normally do new year's resolutions but
i was like okay this year i'm gonna find
a church
um it's gonna happen and it was right
before the pandemic
and i started looking and i really
wanted an
inclusive community and i went to a
couple different churches
and just didn't find the values that i
was looking for
and then i found the table and i was
like all right i'm going to go i'm going
to go it's going to be awesome
and then the pandemic happened and so i
didn't go
because nobody could go and it took us a
while to get online
and it just was in the back of my heart
and i went
online to a different community because
you guys weren't online yet
but i kept checking back cause i was
like i mean we're gonna be here for a
while
eventually we'll have an online service
and i just knew
it just was that feeling i went through
the website
um i was a creep you know i looked at
all the by everybody's faces before i
came
um but yeah it was uh like instant as
soon as i heard your first message i was
just like this is
very very cool how about um in terms of
what kind of
pushed you a little bit or kind of
nudged you towards like okay i
want i think i want to be a member here
like that's you know and you kind of
already have kind of looted it out so
maybe you've already answered that but i
didn't want to throw it out there if
there was anything else that was like
that was the thing that
nudged me towards it so i grew up in
church um and i grew up in a very very
strict church
um where i was almost kind of forced to
become a member
um from i grew up from the age of one to
that church to
22. um sorry so
uh it was without going too much into
detail
it was really difficult and it
definitely defined my identity
for a long time and so i did become a
member of that church at a very young
age
not really understanding what that meant
um and so when i found the table it was
something that i wanted
as an adult to be able to be a part of a
community that i believe in
and that i feel like god is here and god
is with me
yeah what would it um what would it look
like for
us as a kind of a church community to
you know i don't know how to quite how
to put it like to love you well or
support you be there for
you what how how can we do that like
best i feel like you already are
i've met so many new people um just
really
smiling even through the mask you know
and just being real you know i think
that's the
biggest thing is just having real
relationships and being in people's
lives
i just want that more you know so if i
haven't met you i would love to meet you
awesome well um i'm gonna
i'll just encourage you all that if you
get a chance after the service like come
up
say hey connect with mariah give her you
know the welcome all that
and uh just make sure that she feels
really loved and special and all those
things so
ryan thank you we're so glad to have you
as a part of us
it's really exciting so can you give her
a hand
[Applause]
awesome all right let me send you out
um you are god's servants you're gifted
with dreams
you're gifted with visions and upon you
rest the grace of god like flames of
fire
go love serve the lord
in the strength of the holy spirit you
all are dismissed have a great week
do
[Music]
so
dude
[Music]
you